we continue our coverage of the uvalde
texas the latest unspeakable act of gun
violence in this country an 18 year old
male walked into robb elementary school
yesterday he had an
ar-15 rifle
so you heard he went classroom to
classroom opening fire and everyone in
his way at least 19 children
little children and two teachers were
killed they were just two days away from
summer vacation i can't stop thinking
about that the massacre reminds us of
this horrific shooting that killed 26
people at sandy hook elementary school
in newtown connecticut that was nearly
10 years ago now it was a crime at the
time that shook us all to the core
scott pelley anchor of the cbs evening
news said this on the day of that
shooting
we have been through this too many times
those are the words of president obama
and the thoughts of all of us after
another mass shooting in america
it is a crime more horrific than many
could have imagined in a place that no
one would have expected here in the
idyllic new england community of newtown
connecticut today a gunman opened fire
on school children in a kindergarten
classroom
earlier today a number of our citizens
beautiful children
had their life taken away from them six
seven st hook school callers indicating
she thinks there's someone shooting in
the building i saw some of the bullets
going past the hall that i was right
next to
i just heard the principal was shot and
killed
i heard
i heard some kids were
shot i missed a teacher mrs hammons was
shot who would have ever thought in
elementary school where the children
as a country we have been through this
too many times
i know there's not a parent in america
who doesn't feel the same overwhelming
grief that i do all these parents were
waiting for their children to come out
they thought that they were
you know still alive
there's 20 parents that were just told
that their children are dead
[Music]
it was awful
it was ten years ago connecticut senator
chris murphy was a congressman
representing the families of sandy hook
elementary school
since then the democrat has worked in
congress to try and pass tougher gun
laws and senator murphy joins us now
senator i look at those images and i'll
never forget that day i know you won't
either because i know you were there but
yesterday i was watching you on
television i felt your pain i felt your
passion
it literally jumped through me jumped
out of the tv screen to me chris when
you started begging your colleagues
begging your colleagues so i'm wondering
what has been the reaction have you
heard from them have they said we hear
you we believe you now is the time to do
something what are they saying to you
today
i mean listen i i just worry that we are
becoming numb to this that we are
accepting this as the new normal we just
need to remind ourselves that this is
the only place in the world that this
happens there's not a single country in
the world in which kids fear for their
lives when they walk into school in the
morning it's our choice we can do
something about this and so
yes i've been on the phone texting with
my colleagues all yesterday this morning
trying to find some common ground listen
no secret that i think these assault
weapons designed to kill human beings as
quickly as possible have no place in
civilized society but i'm willing to
compromise and so i've made clear to my
republican colleagues i'm open for
business um if you have a compromise if
you have something that you think can
make our country a little bit safer it
can make our kids and our families a
little bit safer let's get it done and
so my hope is over the next 24-48 hours
that they'll be you know 10 or 15
republicans of good conscience that will
watch what these parents are going
through in texas and come to the table
and try to find some way to make sure
that this doesn't happen at least as
often as it does now as a parent who is
sending his two school-age kids off to
school this morning again
knowing that those kids are talking to
each other today about whether their
school is next week
imagine the conversations that parents
are having with their children this
morning we we were told that you were
talking to senator manchin this morning
can you share where he stands on this
issue
well you know senator manchin was you
know one of the leaders uh after sandy
hook in trying to find bipartisan
compromise on expanding background
checks and so
senator mancha and i were just on the
phone we're going to be reaching out to
republicans today to see if we can find
some of that
common ground whether it's on red flag
laws trying to take guns away from folks
who show significant signs of
impending danger or whether it's a
smaller expansion of the background
check system we're going to reach out to
republicans try to find something that
we can do together this year right now
senator you've talked about common sense
gun legislation what does that actually
look like to you
you know what's wild is that this issue
is only controversial inside washington
dc outside washington dc there's more
consensus on common sense gun
legislation than on almost any other
topic 90 of americans think that every
gun purchase should come with a
background check the majority of
republicans in this country don't think
that assault weapons should be legal so
when i say common sense gun legislation
i mean changes in our gun laws that are
supported by a cross-section of gun
owners and non-gun owners republicans
and democrats in this country
this is an issue that outside of this
place actually has tons of consensus and
you know that's the gap that we're
trying to close here
senator no place is sacred no person is
safe even your colleagues in congress
have been
targeted on a baseball field no less
practicing for a game so at what point
are the people who are
tasked with
giving legislation for a bill that as
you say is bipartisan going to act is it
going to take an act by the president an
executive order of some kind
i think there's only so much that the
president can do on his own
you know a lot of my republican
colleagues still labor under this
mythology that
more guns make us safer well you heard
the reporting just minutes ago from
texas
there were armed police officers outside
that school when the gunman arrived and
they could not stop him in part because
he had weapons that were just as if not
more powerful than
the police had our police are out gunned
today by these shooters and so we've got
to disabuse members of congress of this
idea that the way to protect kids is to
put more weapons in our schools
obviously that didn't work here what we
have to do is make sure that the killers
don't have weapons that are more
powerful than law enforcement
senator i just think we really need a
hero here in the senate we need a hero
in this country you know it's democrats
blame republicans republicans blame
democrats what if the focus was somehow
just focused on the children right i
don't know anybody republican or
democrat if you just say this is about
children because it it keeps happening
over and over and over again and nothing
ever changes
how do we get to people to get to
people's hearts to say what can we do
you know it's more heinous to me that
these were elementary school kids who
were just sitting in their desks with
their baby teeth i cannot stop thinking
about that and i know you know the same
thing about newtown why not just ask
people how do you feel about children we
say we care about children in this
country over guns
that doesn't seem to be the case based
on the actions that have been taken
before
yeah and that's what i said on the floor
yesterday you know why i spent all this
time get coming to congress
running for the united states senate and
then do
nothing do nothing slaughter after
slaughter so i think democrats need to
be very clear that we are not going to
insist on the perfect we are willing to
compromise but i think voters and
parents have to stand up right now and
tell their members of congress in
particular they're republican members of
congress come to the table and support
um compromise and if you don't we're not
interested in you representing us
anymore i think that's what parents all
across the country have to say is that
listen we're not going to send you back
to washington if your answer in the face
of these murders is to sit on your hands
ultimately we've got to be responsible
but voters have got to take
responsibility as well
senator you told us that you just talked
to mention has any other republicans
reached out to you since this has
happened yeah i was in touch yesterday
with some of my republican friends in
particular the two texas uh senators uh
in the past uh senator cornyn of texas
has been um willing to sit down at the
table and talk about potential
compromise i'll spend most of today
trying to see if there's that common
ground maybe we just have to force a
vote maybe we just have to put a bill on
the floor of the senate and and and
force an up or down vote but before we
do that let's take some time to try to
find a way to
maybe engage in some compromise on
background checks on red flag laws on
you know exactly who's able to buy these
assault weapons
senator thank you so much we appreciate
you